you
hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game from round two of the
Sinquefield Cup 2018 on the white end
Magnus Carlsen and he's paired against
Sergei Kuryakin so let's dive in and see
how this marathon game played out it
lasted nearly seven hours time controls
100 minutes apiece you gained 30 seconds
when you make a move and each player
gains one hour and move 40 it ran 88
moves so what to note about the opening
something quickly to note after a three
black cannot win upon by giving up the
bishop for Knight and then taking on c4
95 picks the pawn right back up so the
Bishop's maintained with d4 white
secures the knight position so castling
instead would allow black to play d4 and
the knight asked to find a new home so d
takes e4 and we go down this path one
where we now have a case of opposite
color bishops this is basically the
starting point of this game this is the
mane and bounce the one square that
sticks out to me more than any other is
h3 it's an irreparable weakness it's not
every day you see white go forward with
a g3 fiend cut oh and not long after
give up that Bishop for a knight
what has white received well white has
compromised blacks Queen side structure
by going in for this exchange white also
has some weaknesses on the Kings side to
be careful about at some point blacks
Bishop can be a slight pest if it gets
to h3 before white castles and I say
slight because there's a way to work
around it it would not be uncommon to
see f3 and the King camp out on f2 it's
not ideal but it's reliable enough of a
home for the white king
okay well from here Queen a for black
strikes at white center with the C pawn
believe we could also see e5
okay c5 in this game and I think it's
worthwhile to draw some attention to the
clock times karyakin basically hasn't
blinked and a dozen moves in only spent
about maybe 15 minutes I think this has
an influence on Carlson's next decision
maybe staying clear of going for a pawn
grab is a good idea for white you know
white could try to win a pawn like this
but it's opening up White's up upon
maybe not that big of a factor not as
much of a factor as activating the
bishop in this position Carlsen places
an emphasis on development is what I'm
getting out captures on c5 develops the
bishop develops the rook and after
Knight to d5 Bishop d4 is not so quick
to open up the bishops eyes to that
weakened h3 square not yet at least
from here we have rook to d8 and it's
only at this point do we have Knight
takes Knight black cannot recapture with
the rook unless he wants to get made it
so you have to take with the pawn notice
the timing of it right
white is only going in for that exchange
after black has exhausted a move with
rook to d8 this post is now no good for
the rook the bishops eyes are opened but
in a way black kind of wastes a move the
rook will have to reposition there's
nothing exciting happening on the D file
like is never going to get in d4 white
has you know more than enough control
over that point now White's next move
was played pretty quick Queen c2 and
this is the one move that when I made my
first pass through this game I thought
to myself that's weird I would have
castled here I wouldn't have wanted to
see Bishop to h3 but you know it's not a
big deal apparently to white if Bishop
h3 is in because of f3 King f2 and
everything's cool Kuryakin sees it
similar doesn't play Bishop h3 Queen e7
castles Bishop h3 only now rook e1 and
from here just regrouping preparing to
double on the D file rook d4 Queen g5
offering the Queen exchange Queens are
exchanged so now we're entering a
technical endgame so let's see how the
pieces regroup for each side threat here
is maybe e4 the ruckettes off of the D
file so there's no e4 stuff this is not
a good idea to try and defend this point
directly the bishop is good enough of a
defense also the rook on d8 is not a
it's not a reliable post anyhow black
gets off of the D file and white is
improving the King Square for the bishop
on f7 rook d4 rook d2 base point is
covered this rook is now free to do
something else
Bishop f7 and now one tiny move h3
queenside not too much going on with the
Queen side it's static things can change
still on the Kings side white is gearing
up for that g4 on the way white wants to
be able to recapture towards the center
this would not be a wise choice playing
g4 at this stage white would black would
just take if you take with the pawn
you're taking away from the center and
giving up a huge square e for to all the
black pieces and if you take with the
rook what are you doing about this guy
no reason to strand the h-bomb so it's
h3 rook up for a little back-and-forth
g4 is finally in white is keying in on
this square both rooks and after up to
b8 the character of the game has changed
white gives up the exchange captures on
d5 and has now a bishop in pawn for the
rook before you go in for this kind of
exchange sacrifice there are a couple
pieces of criteria you really need to
look into like to draw some attention to
this moment in the game it's a big one
what to know well before you consider
going in for this sequence as white one
thing to check for is will my bishop
have a reliable home the answer to that
is yes the bishop on c3 is very secure
closes down the queenside basically
nothing exciting is happening on the ABC
files another thing will that minor
piece have an influence on the mobility
of my opponents rooks the answer to that
is also yes the queenside
it's difficult to see how the black
rooks get activity in this position on
the whole Queen side I really mean that
ABC files nothing at the moment the
white rook also contributes there's no
action for the rooks along the D file if
black prepares to double target one weak
point
there's always Eve for Black is now
going to struggle some computer if you
stare at the evaluation it says it's a
goose egg just triple zeros but it's
much easier for white to play this
position difficult to coordinate the
black rooks in this position
one other thing black needs to be
careful about white extending the scope
of the bishop on c3 and white is close
to doing that with the move g5 white
would like to exchange the Jeep on for
the F pawn and that way the bishop can
see a little bit further and white at
some point can then target the base
point on the Kings side that base point
could be f6 or g7 depending on how black
reacts to the g5 move so king g6 in the
game it's fighting against this g5 move
by fighting against this g5 move black
is also giving up the c4 pawn king g6
rook c5
this pond is gonna be one no is it
better for black to maybe try and hang
on to that pond I'm not so sure about
that
that would mean basically crawling up in
a completely passive position so for
example instead of king g6 if black
plays rook here rook d6 rook e8 that is
completely passive maybe even a 45 can
hit you'd really don't want to go
passive like this as black King g6 in
the game eventually the material is
balanced we have two pawns in a bishop
versus a rook but again it's much easier
for white to play this is great on the
Queen side so let's see how play
develops is there an opportunity at this
point here's another thing to consider
is there an opportunity for black to
give the exchange back the answer to
that is no so for example at this stage
can black take the bishop and then play
your rook to b3 and be alright no
because there's the move a4 if ruk takes
c3 this pawn is going to be hunted down
and if Rick a3 why could defend rook c4
is nearby and if you don't pick up the
pawn now you know everything is still
defended we just enter a position where
white is up to clean pawns so no time
for this it's not an not a good choice
to give the exchange back so rook c6
eyeing this up once more this might be a
different story because you get that
pawn right back and you're then on the a
pawn
so how does white cope with this threat
of giving the exchange back plays a4 so
if black goes in for this capture the
rook isn't going to be hitting the a
pond so once more if this happens this
guy is going to be lost
rook isn't hitting a white pawn pawn
pushes you hit it along a rank once more
White's gonna be up two pawns so still
no time to give the exchange back so we
have a check can you have two everything
is glued together on the Queen side this
is a super bishop
okay four and still no time for this
exchange sacrifice same story keeping
pressure on something the white rook you
four and rook d4 nothing happening on
the Queen side and from here f4 okay so
this is where the things are things are
changing a little bit on the Kings side
looking to play f4 actually me f5
squeeze the King back this you cannot do
looking at this once more might be a
different story because it hits with
check but this would not be a good
choice for black let's say rook here try
and get the pawn back there's e5 and
this is going to be a problem for black
capturing would allow a check and then
other checks this pawn Falls the King's
gonna have a wonderful home on g5 in
short capturing on c3 it's still no good
giving the exchange back rook c7 f5
check rook da I didn't mention this yet
it's important to keep of rook on light
does not want to have a rook exchange
big reason for that if the rooks are
exchanged white will never be able to
question the black Kings post when it's
on a light square this guy needs to be
around to help fight for some light
squares at the moment the white pawns on
the Kings side do a good job of
coordinating with the bishop white also
wants to keep a rook around to fight for
the light squares rook c8 it's declined
once more and rook d4 king f4 notice the
king positions the rooks not really
playing in the king is really just out
of the ballgame on the edge not
contributing white has some space on
both wings a5 and f5
rooks see for King age six keeping this
option open to give a check so if King
g5 here trying to get aggressive it's
gonna lead to mate actually in the game
we have rook to d7
if King g5 it's already a
maintenance-free with check and rook c1
mate soon what do you do about that
nothing rook h1 next is me so can't get
aggressive with King g5 rook d7 Bishop
d4 no activity King h7 b4 look at this
these guys right here are kind of
keeping these rooks just in this section
how do they get activated keeping
control over the rooks so what White's
doing preventing the activity why does
not want to see the rooks get back here
and subject because if the rooks get
active that's going to subject the King
to some problems or won't be able to
rely upon us squares so easily
Sarek d6 King III rook c1 is preventing
king to g5 I didn't throw a pop quiz
your way in this position the King goes
back probably a has some psychological
impact on Kari Aachen at this stage you
know you played it h6 and then your next
move is to return to h7 after about four
minutes you know why why is the King
going back well what would happen if the
King went forward pop quiz
what move should white play here feel
free to pause the video okay there are a
couple of good moves one is Bishop c5
another is rook to h1 I like the Bishop
c5 move it's it's very clear to see what
the idea is now you hit the rook
after the rook moves you would have King
to f3 threatening check and then
checkmate and there's no running you
know the King can't run away now check
and checkmate
black would have to at this point
play rook to d3 in order to stop
checkmate but that would mean black
would have to give up the exchange white
is of course winning in this position so
in short no King to g5 you walk right
into some mating net the king cannot get
active just like the rooks are not
active the King can't get active in this
position either King h7 Bishop b6 and
eventually we have this idea
nearing breaking down this structure
rook e8 can't go in for this just yet
because II four would fall so white
defends and now sensing this g5 advance
black plays g5 this is good resistance
by black very lengthy game easy to go
wrong in many cases pretty strong
defense here by car yakin we've seen
this in the 2016 World Chess
Championship match multiple games where
Carlson was pressing pressing pressing
in car yeah Ken found a way to defend so
some pawns are exchanged on the Kings
side
this guy's now passed on e4 how to get
it rolling rook activity first from
we're move 71 is basically playing off
of the increment bullet mode at this
stage for both sides so let's see how
this wooden finishes up getting the king
activated pawn gets rolling and this is
where Kari Aachen makes the only wonder
of the game plays King to c6 best at
this point apparently still an equal
position with rook to e1 questioning the
king position and if King to d5
continually give checks get block but
black plays rook to d8 and is
threatening to win the bishop with the
discovered check King move computer
recommends rook h4 is one of the moves
king c7 something like this black should
go on a a checking spree basically is
what the computer is suggesting
apparently leads to a draw going for
these checks in the game it's king c6
which is allowing a winning continuation
there's only one winning continuation
one winning move in this position
Carlsen spots it rook h6 check King b6
and another only winning move rook b6 so
the idea is to play e6 but the rook
wants to be on the b6 post first still
keeping a watchful eye on that a6 pawn
so after this check and only then e six
white is subjected to some checks but
White's able to zigzag a little bit and
the checks run out and this pawn gets
rolling this Bishop is enormous
everything is strung together with this
Bishop on c5 it remains a powerhouse in
this game and the plan here is to go to
d8 not much you can really do about that
rook to D
how to stop this move black plays rook
to h8 this pawn is gonna follow though
this is actually the final move of the
game
rook takes a six black resigns three
passed pawns at this point and the
winning way forward if play did continue
rook h7 is maybe one idea another check
but they run out and white could now
interfere with the coordination on EA
EA texts and simple from there this is
as far as it got in this one though
after rook to a six-car Aachen resigned
very lengthy game one blunder after
nearly seven hours tough to continue
finding that resistance and must have
been quite an exhausting game for these
two interesting endgame and this one
exchange sacrifice again those two key
pieces of criteria if you're going to go
in for that kind of exchange sacrifice
do you have stability for that minor
piece will that minor piece have some
influence on the mobility of the enemy
rooks in this case both of those both of
those conditions were met there may be
some others but those are the two that
really stick out to me when considering
some kind of exchange sacrifice anyhow
as usual feel free to leave any feedback
to this video in the comment section
below I hope you enjoyed it and maybe
took a thing or two away that's all for
now take care bye
you